[Music]
all right now to breath of the wild dlc
we were grabbing food the other day
after work and then Rob or one of you
had mentioned oh [ __ ] yeah Pete sorry I
don't mean to give Robin credits too
much it was a conversation stopper
you're like you just knew it right
before my gosh it was really ideal guys
it came at the perfect time too because
I think a lot of us finally burnt out is
not the right term but I think a lot of
us were finally like I need to put this
down and try to play a lot of other
things because this year has been off to
a fantastic start
and that's an understatement but Zelda
they have announced the first expansion
pass there's another one story base
that's gonna come out sometime holiday
this year but the first expansion the
master trials was detailed in depth here
you have Southeast Asia shots and
everything so trial is sword sounds
really cool if you played Twilight
Princess it sounds similar to the Cave
of trials I might begin that wrong but
it was out in the desert but you go
through 45 rooms starting with almost
nothing
almost like event I'd island if you
played that and you looks like you just
start with a Deku stick on your back
yeah here's hero's path mode which oh I
just here's path mode it's gonna track
you're travelling across the in-game map
so you can kind of see where you explore
yeah so you don't have to look up the
actual map online for where the shrines
are or core exceeds even yeah you get it
because I usually use shrines to kind of
dictate [ __ ] I haven't explored here
enough for I have explored here enough
how is this going to take into account
fast travel it's gonna pretend as though
you walked there oh it's actually the
maps like 10 hours in it's just a bunch
of well yeah yeah like it's like uh I
think 80 hours and I realized I hadn't
even been to East neckla duh
yeah like it all I was like oh [ __ ] so
that would have been really helpful you
guys 200 hours right
I was out at sedge I think it's x2 in
two hours the people that were playing
in those videos stick to pathways much
more than I do I it looked like they
weren't climbing like I just I climb
every chance I get like I don't know
take the shortest point from A to B
possible shorts line I like missed a
place in on Death Mountain because I
just climbed up the mountain yeah
then there is a hard mode it's kind of
self-explanatory for most parts just uh
bobgoblin's and mob ones and enemies in
general are increased in rank so maybe
you'll see more white bow cabins more
often no no no it's that they they take
on the strength of the rank above them
so red will be as strong as blue yeah
it'll be red there's not gonna be like a
new coach rank for them yeah oh I didn't
I thought I was like a whole shift okay
no it's just yeah now they're one step
up harder they're also be in this is the
one locations like this I know I know
it's weird I the reason I don't like
this idea of balloons with a mob 'ln
just hanging out up in the sky what like
why I don't know the whole this this
game is so immersive and I just find
like nuts but what is this what I don't
like the hideouts you come across those
boy tree forts those make sense they're
outpost for them to kind of like guard
yeah well I mean this is good yeah well
yeah this guy is just keeping watch
right like you can see a lot farther you
can warn them of some more come here
with the balloons yeah but those pops so
quickly
nothing is high yeah I'm hung up on this
- this is like I just don't need to chew
on guy yeah don't worry about that it's
miners help I said something works like
I don't I added I wonder how that's
gonna play in because I just love the
game already you doing you did make a
good point like it seems odd doesn't
seem as organic Yeah right yeah um if
you complete the 45 room trial of the
sword challenge the power of the Master
Sword awakens and will always be in its
glowing powered up state when I first
read that before I read it's glowing
powered up state I'm assuming that just
means it will always be at like 40
attack and it won't j6o about 16 does it
say that it won't break no it just says
it always be telling me not I guess they
should and they didn't say that but so
Willie it says will always be in its
glowing powered up state right when
usable is the actual next few were right
so it's twice don't worry
so it does for so what is the and it
needs to break cuz that's what just was
saying like huh well then you're not
doing the actual system of the weapons
like switching our weapons it would be
boring and we maybe it would be
frustrating if they do that so that's
read that I was hoping it would be the
the classic Master Sword when you have
full hearts power up you shoot out a
beam you can use you that already with
the Master Sword yeah yeah in breath of
the wild yes there you go that's the
Ganga squash and learnin everyday I play
the 80 hours that game I have the Master
Sword why do I know that I have two
hearts and you just do the throw like
try to throw it and you'll it'll be like
a yang okay um I'm really excited for
that Korac mask yeah vibrates when you
do that Roxy penis nine hundred karate
is way too damn many yeah so I'm excited
about some of the new armor oh my god I
didn't even notice the pinwheel that's
really cute oh look a little bun I love
Lake yeah it's the army and I this is so
minor the only thing I would say is that
like I do find the game or camera can be
very menu intensive I just feel like I
mean I don't want to look like this
forever
yeah but well I now have it on always
when I'm running around I don't know
exploring I think when you cuz I have
300 core exceeds right now and I'm at
the point where I would really like this
just because you need 441 to max all
your inventory slots that's sort of my
goal for a while but I hit 300 and I was
super fatigued on it yeah so what is
like the max melee weapon capacity um
it's I think it's probably the entirety
of that first payday right so many that
those narrows are different there's
fewer slots for four bows and then
shields is also the full page I don't
know how many it's like above 20 okay
and you can also have Majora's Mask
which I'm pumped about I don't so you
know it does we don't know and we're
actually like Joey's working on a cool
video we're not gonna speculate I think
we have some good ideas I'm not this is
the one actually I don't know I'm
thinking maybe something with the Blood
Moon like you get like maybe like a
powerup cuz I don't know something
time-based tabria oh that's a good call
that one's question well thank the other
ones we had better ideas of what they
could be like tingle
I don't someone someone had the just
like you have the core rack mast to find
or exceed maybe the tingle
would like light up for fairies they're
nearby cuz those are always hard to find
and like on a risky forget hot yeah he'd
I said earlier he reminds me of like the
scene in a Christmas story or yeah he
just looks so not into the fit okay
deadline so get going take the picture
mom I'm ready to get out of this like
never ever gonna wear this I'll wear it
all the time and then the other one or
there's two of them don't the other one
is the Phantom armor kind of forget what
someone said someone in the office had a
good idea what maybe this was like you
know do looks like a dark nut from
Twilight Princess the enemy I kind of
gotta look love it I kind of love this
one mm-hmm
yo first full body suit right you said
that Maria looks cool yeah I don't like
[ __ ] costume yeah I guess we even then
you can see links face like you can't
see anything
yeah I yeah I'm excited for this um well
one more thing we want to mention well
Midna Selma to if you played toilet
princess so they're just this is
nitpicky I'm excited to have all these
things but um it seems like they're just
throwing these things into here as like
Easter eggs and kind of fanservice
whatever I'm on board because I like
Majora's Mask and Twilight Princess a
lot there's a travel and alien as well
you want explain that really quick yeah
apparently well what's neat about all
the stuff which I'm excited that they're
you know you know you don't just get
everything you have to go find it you
know look for it so the medallion this
is like summer in the world and it's a
one-time use for anywhere you want fast
travel it's pretty cool I guess like if
you have like if you know of an area
like I was telling you the other day I
found a tree that has every single
mushroom oh so if your environment yeah
you're going to collect cool cooking
recipes you can go sell your medallion
there and always go back to it posted
getting into a shrine and then having
trouble that's so cool for if you farm
something right yeah sweet yeah dragons
uh I'm also interested in how you find
these because for the core Achmed
specifically they said it's just in a
chest somewhere in the world so I wonder
you're going to be coming across people
who have dialogue to kind of mention
this or if it's going to be you're going
to get the masks from what's-his-name I
mean that kind of leads into my question
which is like is all this stuff gonna be
a better experience with a fresh
playthrough yeah like how
how is that going to continue that again
mm I guess I'm inclined I can't I
haven't even I'm at 130 hours I haven't
beaten the game yet I can't just do it I
can't you have to just do it I was
waiting I have two more shrines I'm
gonna do it I've been playing other
games like you want to hit Ganon uh
sooner than later it's way too easy like
when I did it I was like oh this is I
was stalling because I wanted to
experience it but I just completely like
what you do the four dungeons and then
look hearts like I sort of like Ariel
you have all the masks in majora's mask
and you fight and it's like oh that was
faster than I thought makes the journey
more fun though getting all those well
yeah same thing with breath a wild I
think that it's not even about Ganon
that's how I feel like I'm I want to get
all the shrines and then go and I have
two more so yeah all right well that is
the master trials expansion for zelda
they're gonna announce more about the
story based expansion later on in the
year they said that will release holiday
2017 let us know if this is going to
bring you back into breath of the wild
if you've left it are you gonna start a
new game are you just going to start
looking for these things right from your
current savefile let us know also show
us the best pictures you can draw with
that heroes path mode I don't care how
vulgar it is just send it my way
[Music]